what's up this is streetlight here with
new media rockstars um i'm gonna be
freestyling
some different people maybe even see a
rap battle answer some questions
so let's see what happens
here i used to grab the sega genesis
cartridge but now i wrap paper drag the
pencils american companies are going
into indonesia
cutting down rainforest forcing people
into work slavery
and making animals extinct okay so
you should totally rap about that let's
go all right
yo i'ma rap a couple of bars we talk
really hard about
what's going on with the explosions
building bars until we get up into mars
trying to get down with the stars but
instead we got the small
bad companies still trying to rap they
want money from me
but it's not free so there's a cost to
pay the environment i'm not lying wait
until i'm done buying this
now i give money to the big people they
don't give money back to us so
guess what as a people with greenpeace
we're not backing up matter of fact
we get strong strategy tough i got a
couple of scars to show you when you can
have a buck
i don't need that as long as i have the
green behind me and have half a luck
i should be doing just fine and that's
done for asking us
oh my god what what oh my goodness
wow i hold the world record for longest
freestyle heck yeah
how long 13 hours oh my god
that is a long time thanks
i'm a rap about the dog daisy having
something to drink
maybe a little lazy i don't know you
lately we came up to these random two
ladies and said
please guys with a question so i can rap
about it and maybe rape me
i'm having a nice day i do this
freestyle thing on the daily but anyway
i say hello to daisy how you doing i got
a couple dogs back at home
up to some trouble probably brewing so
when i get home open the doors play the
music
i can say what are you doing my dogs
call me stupid but i like to have a
little fun i get down and rap we go
outside
matter of fact have a couple of buns
when it's a day in the sun you could
probably catch me on the beach i just
keep rapping all my dogs want to do is
eat
coins coins okay all right all right
money
money okay i'm a rap about money
freestyle about cash i got a couple
dollars in my pocket a couple in my
secret stash see
you could probably find some in my car
or maybe some in my bag it doesn't
matter because when i slow down
i never lag now i like to rap about a
couple cents and i
have common sense so that's a double
entendre if you get it
i got enough to pay the rent with the
rhymes i admitted i'm committed you can
get those green backs
but guess what to the ceiling key stacks
and i'm trying to
get more dollars and i count them and
get an accountant to sit down with me
until we
burn all of it down to the ground and
then i'm done with my rapping when they
hand me that check
that's all i'm looking for at the end of
the day and i'm not placing no bets
what do you guys think that's good fat
girls
fat girl let's just let's let's not just
do women's
bad people in general um he wants me to
rhyme about
fat people i'm not that evil but i still
say something and wait till i come back
wait he's no i'm trying to get into a
different rhythm so when i get done
spitting
talking about what you had for dinner it
was probably chicken that's all that
comes to mind is food i overdo it just a
little bit i get my sandwich get my stew
in
find some creams maybe add a little bit
of spinach wait until i'm done i'm
having this for dinner i'm finished
what do you think
they want me to rap about cookies wonder
how long it took me to come up with this
i was in the kitchen cooking cooking in
public had people watching hoping i'm
not messing up with this
until i put too many in and i burnt the
oven kid i blew the whole house up now
they flaming just like he asked me for
but don't blame it
on me cause i just did it the way he
asked me to matter of fact i came back
with a casting crew they filming so when
i get my own cooking show
you better watch it buy my book and yo
imma be done these people behind me
talking pounding loud but if i give them
some of my cookies
guarantee they quiet it down
thanks guys thank you thank you
here i used to grab the sega genesis
cartridge but now i wrap paper drag the
pencil across it how is that from being
labeled that's awkward to be in laden
with label office and ours trying to get
their power back with bible verses and
rhymes my vision incline you can use the
future too if you knew what i do between
the lines see
i'm already hearing even though they
tell me that i'm deaf
until death i may never sign the
language that conveys this message is
never